[Aplausos]
[Música]
ya hace casi un año desde que hablamos
por última vez en este canal de la madre
patria del equipo de visualpolitik
España
y con las elecciones generales clavadas
en pleno mes de julio se nos ocurrió que
ya tocaba volver a visitarla pero no
esta vez no hablaremos ni de catástrofe
económica ni de trenes ni tampoco de las
pensiones hoy os venimos a hablar de la
figura que ha estado dominando la
política española desde el 2018
efectivamente queridos amigos amigas de
visualpolitik os hablamos de uno de los
galardonados con nuestro anti premio al
personaje político más decepcionante en
2020 y mención especial anti premios
2022 el presidente del gobierno de
España Pedro Sánchez si vives en España
o conoces de cerca la realidad de este
país te habrás dado cuenta de una cosa
la sociedad está partida en dos y no no
me refiero solo a la clásica división
entre la derecha y la izquierda sino
también entre los que digamos reprueban
rechazan odian a Pedro Sánchez y los que
le aman incondicionalmente de hecho su
Estilo de hacer política ha sido como
decirlo tan rompedor en España que
incluso se le ha catalogado con nombre
propio el sanchismo derogar el sanchismo
en su totalidad
franchismo y al socialismo que no parece
que sea el sanchismo verdad el más
indicado para decirlo
sea eso lo que sea Pero qué es todo esto
del sanchismo si me preguntáis a alguien
de la oposición seguramente os diga
directamente que es la concentración de
manipulación maquiavelismo y mentiras
desenfrenadas para mantener el poder a
toda Costa eso y también intentar poner
todas las instituciones del estado al
servicio exclusivo del presidente pero
si en cambio le preguntáis a alguien del
partido socialista del que el propio
Sánchez es secretario general os dirán
que no es más que un invento de la
extrema derecha y que en todo caso es
sinónimo de astucia tenacidad y
resistencia sea como sea estaremos de
acuerdo en que Pedro Sánchez no ha
dejado indiferente a nadie durante su
mandato como presidente tanto para bien
como para muy mal pero ahora bien Quién
es realmente Pedro Sánchez Cómo llegó a
la presidencia qué legado deja su
mandato presidencial Cómo se ha manejado
Sánchez en el escenario internacional
Pues bien en este vídeo vamos a
responder a todas
estas preguntas arranquemos
Sánchez el personaje
te hago una pregunta sabes quién es
Pedro Sánchez Sí vale el actual
presidente de España pero no me refiero
Sabes algo de su vida aparte de eso es
curioso porque aunque Sánchez ha
recibido durísimas críticas nunca se ha
hablado demasiado de su vida anterior
algo Bastante inusual
Pedro Sánchez Pérez castejones natural
de Madrid e hijo de una abogada y un
economista Quizás por eso siguió los
pasos de su padre hasta llegar a
convertirse en doctor en 2012 y no aquí
no hablaremos de su polémica tesis pero
si algo está claro es que la economía
nunca ha sido su pasión algo muy
diferente a lo que podemos decir de la
política en 1993 con tan solo 21 años se
afilió el partido al que también estaba
afiliado su padre el partido socialista
obrero español El psoe de esta forma dio
sus primeros pasos en política a finales
de los años 90 primero como asesor de la
europarlamentaria socialista Bárbara
durkov y más tarde como miembro del
gabinete del alto representante de la
ONU en Bosnia el español Carlos
westendoor durante la Guerra de los
balcanes Poco después en 2004 se
convirtió en concejal del ayuntamiento
de Madrid y a partir de entonces su
carrera fue un no parar en 2009 entró al
congreso de los diputados y en 2014 ya
se convirtió en el secretario general
del psoe
sin embargo como cabeza del psoe sus
inicios no fueron en ningún caso
alentadores de hecho perdió dos
elecciones generales entre 2015 y 2016 y
de hecho ese último año las presiones
internas le obligaron a dimitir sin
embargo en 2017 volvió a ganar Las
primarias para convertirse otra vez y
con la mayor parte del aparato de su
propio partido en contra en secretario
general y por fin en 2018 Sánchez se
convirtió en presidente de España pero
para los que nos estáis viendo desde
España si recordáis bien no fue por unas
elecciones
Pedro Sánchez presidente del gobierno
tras sanar la moción de censura rajoy
[Música]
efectivamente Sánchez llegó al poder
gracias a primera moción de censura
exitosa desde la llegada de la
Democracia moderna a España Eso sí en
2019 hubo otra vez elecciones y ahí
Sánchez fue el candidato más votado
Aunque
en mayoría absoluta lo que le llevó a
formar el primer gobierno de coalición
de la Democracia moderna en España lo
hizo con la formación de extrema
izquierda de Pablo Iglesias unidas
podemos comenzó entonces una de las
legislaturas más difíciles polémicas
controvertidas y hostiles que podamos
recordar una legislatura que ha sido
toda una trituradora política Albert
Rivera ciudadanos Pablo Iglesias Pablo
casado no solo eso Durante los últimos
años para la mitad de España Sánchez se
ha convertido en algo así como la
Encarnación del mismísimo demonio
[Aplausos]
pero un momento porque este vídeo no va
de Sánchez sino de su política exterior
Pues bien a grandes rasgos si tuviéramos
que etiquetar a este presidente
pondríamos dos hashtags multilateralista
y europeísta algo que la verdad no
supone ninguna novedad todos los
presidentes del gobierno de España desde
la llegada de la Democracia han seguido
prácticamente esa misma línea
la Unión Europea es una realidad que
hemos construido varias generaciones de
europeos que ha dado grandes resultados
y que queremos que compartan con cada
vez mayor intensidad las generaciones
venideras Claro que un momento porque la
etapa de Sánchez ha ido mucho más allá
así que la pregunta es Cuál ha sido
realmente La Apuesta internacional de
Pedro Sánchez Pues bien veámoslo
en pocas luces y muchas sombras
[Música]
a ver si hay algo que se le tiene que
reconocer no solo a Sánchez sino a la
mayoría de líderes mundiales es que
estos últimos años no han sido nada
fáciles la toma de Hong Kong en 2019 la
pandemia en 2020 la caída de kabul en
2021 la invasión rusa de Ucrania en el
22 la crisis energética la crisis de
inflación no hablamos precisamente de un
camino de rosas aún así Sánchez Ha
logrado cosechar algunos digamos más o
menos éxitos a nivel internacional por
ejemplo logró que la Cumbre de la otan
en 2022 se celebrará en Madrid a finales
del mes de junio dada la Guerra de
Ucrania fue una Cumbre absolutamente
crucial en esa Cumbre se acordó la
estrategia en Ucrania la adhesión de
Suecia y de Finlandia y también se
aprobó un nuevo concepto estratégico
para el futuro de la otan es decir el
documento esencial marca los objetivos
compartidos por sus miembros y Oye esa
Cumbre se celebró en Madrid pero
todo Sánchez también se reunió en marzo
de este mismo año en China lo hizo con
motivo del 50 aniversario del
reconocimiento de España al gigante
asiático y bueno Se cerraron algunos
acuerdos y dado el contexto
internacional la reunión fortaleció la
imagen de España como actor influyente
en la Unión Europea más hostil hacia
china que podamos recordar y bueno
también podríamos poner sobre la mesa
algunos logros en sus negociaciones en
Europa por ejemplo convertirse en uno de
los mayores receptores de los fondos
next generation o conseguir
prácticamente Carta blanca para hacer y
deshacer sin que Bruselas se entrometa
demasiado las relaciones de Sánchez y la
presidenta de la comisión europea Úrsula
bonder Legend han sido particularmente
buenas sin embargo lo cierto Es que no
hay mucho más siento decirlo pero tal y
como ha ocurrido con la política
nacional el historial de Sánchez tiene
más sombras que luces
Alemania Deja fuera a España del escudo
antimisiles europeo
Alemania Francia Italia crean una
alianza industrial trilateral y dejan
fuera a España
dicho de otra forma que España a pesar
de ser la cuarta economía más grande de
toda la Unión Europea ha quedado
excluida de varios proyectos en los que
participan sus socios comunitarios y
luego tenemos el caso de Ucrania sí es
cierto tal y como hicieron el resto de
los líderes occidentales Sánchez no
tardó en condenar la invasión y es
verdad España ha contribuido a los
esfuerzos occidentales por ejemplo ha
reforzado las posiciones de la otan
mandando cazas eurofighter y f18 a la
frontera con Rusia en Bulgaria y en
lituania ha mandado a Ucrania cascos
vehículos blindados artillería de 155
milímetros uniformes de invierno e
incluso 10 leopards 2 aceptado a miles
de refugiados ucranianos y para
diciembre del 2022 se habían invertido
282 millones de euros en el fondo
europeo para la paz que está ayudando a
financiar los esfuerzos bélicos de
Ucrania pero creéis que son aportaciones
sustanciales pues nada más lejos de la
realidad
5 de marzo de 2023 España el país
occidental que menos ha apoyado militar
y económicamente Ucrania en el primer
año de conflicto las entregas
bilaterales apenas llegan al 0,03% del
pib
Sánchez se llena la boca hablando de
Ucrania lo hace Incluso en kiev pero a
la hora de la verdad nada de nada o para
ser justos más bien casi nada y no
hablemos ya de la ayuda estrictamente
militar esta era la situación a
comienzos del 2023
[Música]
pese a su tamaño España no estaba ni
entre los 10 mayores contribuyentes en
términos absolutos en términos de pib de
hecho ocupaba uno de los últimos puestos
y aunque en 2023 la cosa mejoró
marginalmente por ejemplo con la entrega
de los leoparts Lo cierto es que España
está en una reñida lucha con macron por
ser los primeros por la cola fijaos que
ocurre cuando tenemos en cuenta todas
las ayudas a Ucrania
y no se trata solo de la ayuda en
general el gobierno de Sánchez ha hecho
que el papel de España en uno de los
conflictos más importantes de este siglo
sea más bien poco o nada relevante Claro
que esto no se compara ni mucho menos a
uno de los movimientos más
controvertidos de la política exterior
española en toda la etapa democrática de
que estoy hablando Pues atentos
qué le debe el peso de a Marruecos
en marzo de 2022 nos encontramos con uno
de los vuelcos más importantes de la
política exterior española
Pedro Sánchez de Marruecos y reconoce el
plan de autonomía para El Sahara que
exigía rabat el presidente Envía una
carta al rey para admitir que este
proyecto es la base más seria realista y
creíble para resolver el conflicto
efectivamente queridos amigos amigas de
visualpolitik por primera vez Un
gobierno español reconoció las
aspiraciones marroquíes sobre El Sahara
occidental fue algo que Sánchez hizo de
forma unilateral sin contar siquiera con
el líder de la oposición por cierto
sobre la situación de España y El Sahara
Ya hicimos aquí en visualpolitik un
vídeo que os dejamos en la descripción
El caso es que eso no es todo además
esta decisión entró en conflicto con los
intereses de otro socio principal de
España Argelia y os preguntaréis Qué
importa lo que piensa Argelia pues
importa y mucho
y es que veréis desde que se declararon
independientes los conflictos y las
tensiones entre a huecos no han parado
los choques las escaramuzas los
enfrentamientos y las peleas
diplomáticas han estado a la orden del
día hablamos de dos países que
básicamente no se soportan y os estaréis
preguntando Pero a qué viene tanto
conflicto entre ellos La respuesta es
bastante simple el poder ambos países
están luchando por convertirse en la
principal potencia del norte de África y
en esa pugna todo vale
De esta forma cuando Marruecos mostró su
apoyo a los secesionistas de la región
de la cabilia en Argelia y tras
descubrirse que más de 6000 teléfonos de
altos cargos políticos habían sido
espiados desde Marruecos con el software
israelí pegasus Argelia decidió romper
toda relación diplomática con su vecino
hace dos años y no solo eso cerró todo
su espacio aéreo para vuelos procedentes
de Marruecos tanto civiles como
militares sin embargo ese no fue el
golpe más duro de este tiraya floja
Argelia corta el mayor de sus gasoductos
con España por la crisis con Marruecos
el presidente argelino del Magic de
confirma la rescisión del contrato a
causa de las prácticas hostiles de
rábate hacia argel
efectivamente queridos amigos de
visualpolitik Argelia una de las mayores
potencias gasísticas de África cortó de
repente el gasoducto mcgrego Europa que
llegaba hasta España cruzando por
Marruecos esto le supuso un duro golpe a
Marruecos que de repente dejó de recibir
gas y también los derechos de tránsito
pero sabéis a quién más le afectó
gravemente Exacto a España que pasó a
contar solamente con el gasoducto
metgash que la conecta directamente a
Argelia dicho de otra forma España
sufrió un duro golpe a su seguridad
energética Pero atentos porque la
situación iba a empeorar aún más
[Música]
antes semejante escenarios Sánchez se
decantó totalmente por Marruecos cesó a
su ministra de exteriores González gaia
solo una semana después de que rabat lo
exigirá y aceptó el plan del gobierno
marroquí para el Antiguo territorio
español en Sahara Pues bien El caso es
que el reconocimiento de las
pretensiones marroquíes sobre el Sacra
occidental por parte Sánchez no hizo más
que enfurecer Argelia y es que hay que
tener en cuenta que desde que España
abandonó el Sáhara en 1975 y Marruecos
la colonizó con la famosa marcha verde
Argelia ha acogido a miles de refugiados
a haraways y apoyado activamente al
frente polisario el principal movimiento
de liberación del Sáhara occidental
es decir que España perdió su principal
baza estratégica de expresión a
Marruecos se desentendió de un
compromiso histórico encima se pegó con
Argelia su principal suministrador de
gas en medio de una crisis energética
6 de octubre de 2022 Argelia encarece el
precio del gas que envía a España en su
revisión del contrato con naturgy para
2022 que sigue negociando para 2023
Además desde entonces Argelia ha
interrumpido buena parte del comercio
bilateral entre los dos países además de
priorizar a países europeos como Italia
respecto a España para todo tipo de
proyectos de futuro de hecho el
movimiento de Sánchez no podía haberse
dado en un peor momento pensando bien en
un escenario en el que la seguridad
energética estaba vendiendo de un hilo
tras el bloqueo a Rusia España se podía
haber convertido en uno de los actores
claves del suministro energético de
Europa una posición que ocupará Italia y
ya sé lo que os estaréis preguntando qué
saca España de semejante cambio pues lo
cierto Es que no está nada claro el
beneficio no parece verse por ninguna
parte de hecho este histórico movimiento
ni siquiera ha hecho que Marruecos deje
de reclamar ceuta y melilla
27 de mayo 2023 rabat se refiere ya como
ciudades marroquíes en un escrito de
censura contra un vicepresidente de la
comisión Europea hay quien dice que fue
una forma de relajar unas tensiones como
Marruecos que estaban peor que nunca hay
quien dice que también tuvo que ver con
de terrible incidente que ocurrió apenas
unas semanas antes del cambio de postura
investigación de la bbc como la policía
española vio hoy no impidió que decenas
de migrantes murieran en su frontera con
Marruecos
la onunista España Marruecos a
investigar las muertes en la frontera de
melilla
los supervivientes del Salto de melilla
denuncian que la guardia civil los
golpeó y devolvió a Marruecos a personas
heridas
y otros apuntan a otro tipo de factores
más o menos sospechosos por ejemplo que
Marruecos hubiera usado el sistema
pegasus para espiar al propio Sánchez o
a miembros de su gobierno así se Podrían
haber enterado de que España le estaba
prestando atención médica al líder del
frente polisario brahim Gali algo que
irritó sobre manera a Marruecos pero sea
como sea el caso es que cada día que
pasa el cambio de postura de Sánchez
Parece uno de los mayores errores que se
recuerdan desde un punto de vista de la
Real política el Sáhara y la relación
con Argelia eran las grandes bazas para
llegado el caso presionar a Marruecos
ahora eso es historia
[Música]
ya veis amigos la presidencia de Pedro
Sánchez no ha estado exenta de polémicas
tanto internas como externas y siendo
honestos no podemos decir que desde el
punto de vista de la política exterior
Sánchez haya dejado España en una
posición mejor que cuando llegó en otras
palabras que España sigue siendo en el
panorama internacional tan
insignificante sino más como cuando
llegó a la moncloa pero llegados hasta
aquí turno para ti crees que España es
más relevante en el plano internacional
hoy que hace 10 años cómo valoráis el
movimiento de Sánchez sobre Marruecos
podéis dejarnos vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios Por cierto en nuestro canal
hermano en visual economic estamos
publicando varios vídeos especiales
sobre la situación económica de España
estamos desmontando algunos mitos y
también os vamos a contar en dos vídeos
especiales Cuáles son los mayores retos
a los que se enfrenta España os dejo
algunos enlaces abajo en la descripción
como siempre no olvidéis Que aquí en
visualpolitik sacamos vídeos nuevos
Todas las semanas así que suscribíos a
este canal y dadle a la campanita para
no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle al botón de like y nos vemos
en el próximo un saludo y hasta pronto
[Música]